by the way you did release that you're
you're separating from your wife I would
imagine this is a a tough thing for you
too because you you you love your kids
you love parenting was this a horrible
thing for you to have to go public with
I mean people invest in it too right
like so all your friends invest in it uh
your family invests in it
um and why and the notion of having to
be public about something sucks too like
why why do you have to but but um kind
of do in this position right because
your life is that's what would you sign
up for it yeah I love her she is my best
friend and an incredible mother and we
are going to be great parents to our
kids
and relationships are so complex
um we were over we were together over a
decade
wow uh and we went we split up got back
together it kind of like
kind of one of those like can't live
can't live without things you know
is that the hardest thing in the world
to to after you split up to go back to
someone it does it's a very difficult
right it felt like it just was It was
supposed to happen you know I mean it's
like one of those things where it's like
it just happened because it was supposed
to happen and now here we are four years
later and and uh at the close of of a
chapter and it feels
it's hard feels like mourning for me to
be honest
um m-o-u-r but uh it also feels like you
know I'm just on the path that I'm
supposed to be on in life and so do you
think it is
do you guys think especially for
musicians with with the covid lockdown
do you think that puts strains on
relationships that are so unnatural I
mean that you know you guys are used to
going on the road you guys are used to
having a certain amount of Separation
too from your family and your spouse
which sometimes can be healthy do you
think that covid contributed to the
dissolution of your relationship at all
no I actually think kovid was for us a
great time because I got to spend a
bunch of time with my kids at home
there's no more Road it was just be home
and I know for some people it's like
wait not to be around you all the time I
can't stand you
um that wasn't that wasn't the part of
the relationship that was hard we really
enjoyed that time and felt very grounded
I gotta like take you know walk the dog
every day and like make breakfast and
like be dad and that was wonderful